people keep saying that apple is ripping
us off with the 8 GB M3 14-in MacBook
Pro and they might be right and today we
will find out because I have this 8 GB
model in an identical one but with 16
gigs on the right hand side so we are
going to do a bunch of real world tests
and we're going to see just how bad is
the base model or is it a great value
now thankfully when we opened these up
we saw that they used two nand chips and
that means that the ssds are not going
to be slowing down the system like with
the M2 machines and typically if you're
just running benchmarks you don't see
much of a difference which is why I
always like to use multitasking real
world tests one thing that I have found
is when we're going from the M1 to the
M2 Chip and now to the M3 when you have
more performance it requires more RAM
and I was shocked that even in cine
bench we are getting a higher score just
running that Benchmark with the only
difference being Ram that is an 11%
difference in performance and I have
never seen that and then with blender we
also were getting crashes on the 8 gig
version and some of you reached out and
said that's because there's not enough
RAM for the performance of that chip so
this is getting crazy I'm going to start
out with restarting both of these
machines to make sure we have nothing
extra loaded in the background and right
after the restart our 16 gig One is
using more RAM because it has more air
to breathe
compared to only having eight now I'm
going to start out by opening up some
websites I have Google Drive I have
YouTube Let's do an MKBHD video in the
background because I often am listening
to a podcast or a video or music and
then a website a lot of these will have
ads that will replay and this is a much
more real world way to test instead of
having nothing open but one Benchmark
and now this is speedometer 2.1 it's
going to test responsiveness for web
browsing and using web-based
applications and both of these these are
great scores but you can see the 8 gig
is already being slightly less
responsive with just a few things open
and many of you guys say you never have
five things open you have 20 30 40
different tabs especially those that
care about productivity and now I have
blender opened up right here and I'm
going to go ahead and do this render
test keep in mind there's almost nothing
else in the background and unfortunately
just like before we got a crash here
people are saying it's because of not
enough Graphics memory for the per
performance whereas the 16 gig is doing
this render now there's really no point
to compare this performance because it's
not running but one thing that I noticed
is when we go into the settings the 16
gig gives us the ability to use rate
tracing that comes with M3 but the 8 gig
one that is not even there and looking
at our RAM usage the 8 gig model is
actually riding Ram to the SSD in the
form of swap cuz it doesn't have enough
RAM whereas a 16 gig is not having an
issue and I've seen this kind of thing
before where certain programs will not
give you full acceleration if you don't
have enough RAM and now I have Adobe
Lightroom classic opened with 50 edited
images let's check out our
responsiveness of course we have fast
ssds in these machines both of them are
doing pretty well and keep in mind we
have not much open in the background and
now let's go ahead and Export 50 of
these images and 50 is actually not very
much there's one guy that's a
photographer tests a th000 at one time
and when I did wedding photography we
would sometimes do 1,000 2,000 and look
at that right there look how much faster
the 16 gig is going in this case even
the 16 gig is using some swap but not
5.6 gab like we are on the 8 gig all
right guys wow now we already tested it
out with nothing running but Lightroom
took a minute and 40 seconds so we see
it slowed down just by having five web
browsing tabs open but the 16 gig
version even with that took a minute and
6 seconds which pretty much matches up
with an M2 Pro MacBook Pro performance
has more cores more graphics performance
that is impressive and that right there
shows you that 16 gigs really unlocks
the M3 chip even without having multiple
programs opened up now no matter which
Mac you have our sponsor app Clean myc
Mac X is the only app you need to keep
your Mac running like new I bought and
have been using it for 4 years now on
many Macs because it is the easiest and
quickest way to protect optimize and
clean your Mac it deletes files quickly
and automatically including hidden
leftover junk files which is important
but the lens tool also finds junk you
didn't know about like 55 GB of backups
that was wasting space it could also
update apps clean up cash monitor health
and protect from Trojans data Miners and
high hijackers the feature I use most is
the menu app to monitor my Mac and when
it feels slow free up my memory with
just one click clean my Mac X is rarely
discounted but for this Black Friday
season they have the best deal that I've
seen so don't miss out and use the link
in the description to get 30% off annual
licenses for yourself and as a gift for
your loved ones you will be glad that
you did and now let's take this a step
further and open up Chrome here with
some more web browsing tabs much more
like a typical person would be using and
I I also opened up a few emails and a
few spreadsheets and Google Docs here so
we have a total of 20 various tabs I
also found this interesting article on
Mac Rumors where apple is saying that 8
gigs on a MacBook is the same as 16 gigs
on a PC so you shouldn't be upset with 8
gigs this is perfect timing and now I
saw a delay opening Lightroom on the 8
gig compared to the 16 gig and switching
photos the 16 gig is more responsive and
the same thing when I zoom in the 16 gig
is instant even hitting the file tab to
do an export test everything is just
taking longer and rendering again the 16
gig is flying before the 8 gig even
starts now while we are doing this let's
do some multitasking let's switch
through these tabs you guys can see how
much quicker the 16 gig model is the 8
gig is taking dramatically longer having
to reload that from SSD even though the
SSD is much quicker than before and it
looks like our Lightroom export is done
on the 16 gig model I pressed this one
first this one opened up first and this
thing is what 20% not even 15% done
maybe the 16 gig didn't slow down at all
compared to the first test so let's go
ahead and do this again and we'll see if
it can actually Loop the 8 gig model
look at this the 16 gig is done whereas
the 8 gig is at about half so that means
that the 16 gig can do this four or five
times before the 8 gig does it one time
and if you guys check out this
performance right over here you can see
that with the 16 gig we were maximizing
our Graphics cores using a lot of CPU
whereas the 8 gig model it's using about
half of the CPU and half of the GPU
because it simply doesn't have enough
RAM to be able to run at full
performance all right guys I waited
until this machine finished and that
took 5 minutes and 16 seconds compared
to 2 minutes when we did the test the
first time or a minute 47 when there was
no application open other than Lightroom
whereas the 16 gig even with all that
open in the background it took a minute
and 6 seconds and it was looping it that
is crazy now I was going to push this
much harder like like I've done with
other systems but we know it's just
going to get worse and worse and now I
have Final Cut Pro open I Clos down
Lightroom and I have this 5 minute PR
res raw project and these chips have
really great encoders and decoders and
now let's go ahead and Export this
5minute project theoretically they
should be running at the same speed and
as you guys could see they are
practically running at the same
performance just slightly behind on the
8 gig model that took a minute and 30
seconds compared to a minute and
25 barely any difference and looking at
our RAM usage closing down Lightroom
that helped a lot both are using some of
the SSD as RAM but way less than before
so for video editing if you're working
with regular footage or press it's going
to be fairly good as long as you don't
have massive timelines or multi-cam now
it's one of you're working with heavier
projects we have 1% exported compared to
8 to 9% right now we're looking at 4%
compared to 16 so that is what four
times uh faster a pretty huge difference
that took about 5 minutes compared to
over 20 minutes and if you're like me
you're not going to be sitting there
waiting you're going to be multitasking
so let's open up Photoshop and look at
that our export right here just
completely failed when I tried to open
up Photoshop that is a bummer let's go
ahead and open up my Panorama project
over here and I will start the merge wow
guys the 16 gig is flying through this
and remember we're not exporting that
video anymore we're just running
Photoshop here all right guys that took
a minute and 20 seconds compared to a
minute and
53 and the only difference is that we
have 16 gigs of RAM compared to 8 GB and
that shows me enough right there that if
I was using this system I would have
more things open in the background to be
able to multitask and be productive and
and the performance would be even
greater between these two machines and
to answer the original question should
Apple be selling an 8 gig for $1,600
when it's almost
2024 and after doing these tests it is
even worse than I expected and I would
say no they should not be doing that now
unfortunately that would mean that they
would charge probably 1,800 instead of
1,600 they don't really give you free
discounts everything is priced the way
out Apple wants it to be and if you want
to buy one of these machines and you are
somebody who does productivity and
multitasks you absolutely need to get
the 16 gig version but in that case
you're almost at the price of the M3 Pro
that comes with 18 gigs of RAM and a lot
of other capabilities so if you guys
want to see how the M3 compares to the
M3 Pro in a 14in make sure you guys
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there there this has been Max and I'll
see you in the next
[Music]
one